DREW GRIFFIN HAS THIS EXCLUSIVE
REPORT AN A COUPLE FROM
MISSISSIPPI STATE NOW SEPARATED
BY PRISON.
>> MUHAMAD IS AT THE VERY START
OF AN EIGHT YEAR PRISON SENTENCE
FOR TRYING TO JOIN AND HELP
ISIS, A RADICAL EXTREMIST?
HARDLY.
HE'S AS AMERICAN AS YOU AND ME
AND HE GOT INTO THIS MESS
BECAUSE HE FELL IN LOVE.
>> Reporter: HOW DID THIS
HAPPEN?
>> WHERE DO YOU WANT KNOW START
EXACTLY?
>> HIS FRIENDS KNOW HIM AS MO,
BORN AND RAISED IN MISSISSIPPI.
MUSLIM AND NON MUSLIM FRIENDS.
HIT AND MISS WITH THE LADIES.
UNTIL AT MISSISSIPPI STATE
UNIVERSITY IN HIS SENIOR YEAR HE
MET AND FELL HEAD OVER HEELS FOR
A MISSISSIPPI STATE CHEERLEADER
NAMED JALEN YOUNG.
>> YES.
SHE WAS BEAUTIFUL AND THINGS
LIKE THAT.
>> SHE'S AMERICAN TOO.
AND MISSISSIPPI ALL THE WAY.
BUT WITHIN MONTHS MO SAYS JAY
LYNN WAS CHANGING.
CONVERTING TO ISLAM.
CHANGING HER DRESS.
THEN BEGAN INTRODUCING MO TO THE
ONLINE BRAND OF ISLAM SHE HAD
BEEN LEARNING ABOUT.
>> THIS HAPPENED SO FAST.
>> IT DID.
MAYBE WE WERE GOING A LITTLE TOO
FAST.
YOU KNOW.
>> BUT YOU WERE IN LOVE.
YES.
YEAH.
>> AND SHE WAS COMING TO YOU,
RIGHT?
>> YEAH.
AND, YOU KNOW, THAT LOVE CAN
ULTIMATELY, YOU KNOW, BLIND OUT
YOUR INTELLIGENCE.
>> THE FEDERAL BUREAU OF PRISONS
RARELY GRANTS ACCESS TO
CONVICTED FELONS LIKE MO.
THIS IS AN EXCEPTION.
AN AGREEMENT WEAN THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE, CNN AND MUHAMED
HIMSELF, PERHAPS FOR ALL TO
UNDERSTAND JUST HOW POWERFUL
ISIS'S ONLINE PROPAGANDA CAN BE.
HIS GIRLFRIEND JAY LYNN YOUNG
MERELY SHOWED MO THE VIDEOS.
THE VIDEOS DID THE REST.
>> WHEN SHE SHOWED ME THAT VIDEO
I THINK IT JUST KIND OF BROUGHT
A TENSENESS IN HER.
YOU KNOW, I FELT THOSE SAME
THINGS, I GUESS, JUST BECAUSE
SHE WAS FEELING IT.
>> AND THAT PROGRESSED.
>> YEAH.
IT PROGRESSED TO THE POINT THAT
I -- MY MIND WASN'T THINKING
STRAIGHT.
>> MO, WHAT WERE YOU GOING TO
DO?
DROP YOUR ENTIRE LIFE AND RUN
OVER TO A WAR ZONE?
>> YEAH.
I MEAN, WHEN SHE FIRST LOOKED AT
THESE VIDEOS, SHE HAD, YOU KNOW,
A STRONG BELIEF THAT OKAY THIS
IS THE GROUP TO REALLY HELP OUT,
YOU KNOW, THE MUSLIMS.
REBUILD TOWNS, PEOPLE WERE
HELPING TO FEED -- FEED THE
NEEDY.
>> ACCORDING TO THE FBI JALEN
YOUNG REACHED OUT TO A CONTACT
SHE THOUGHT WOULD HELP HER AND
MO TRAVEL TO TURKEY.
CROSS THE BOARD ENTIRE THE SYRIA
AND JOIN ISIS.
THE TWO SECRETLY MARRIED.
BEGAN AN INTENSIVE PREPARATION
PERIOD.
AND BOUGHT ONEWAY TICKETS TO
ISTANBUL.
>> ON THE DAY THEY PACKED THEIR
BAGS HE WROTE THIS GOODBYE
LETTER TO HIS PARENTS.
THE FIRST LINE, I LOVE YOU, I'M
SORRY, I'VE DECIDED TO LEAVE AND
WON'T BE COMING BACK.
THEY GOT AS FAR AS AS THE
BOARDING GATE.
>> THE MOMENT THEY ARRESTED YOU?
>> MY HEART SANK.
MY WHOLE BODY SHUT DOWN.
>> TURNS OUT THE ONLINE ISIS
RECRUIT WHO ARE HAD BEEN HELPING
MAKE ARRANGEMENTS FOR THE COUPLE
WAS IN FACT AN FBI EMPLOYEE.
THIS PAST SUMMER THEY BOTH
PLEADED GUILTY.
MO GIVEN AN EIGHT YEAR SENTENCE
CITING HIS COOPERATION WITH
AUTHORITIES.
JALEN YOUNG, THE MASTER MIND WAS
SENTENCED TO 12 YEARS.
SHE'S REFUSED TO SPEAK TO CNN.
>> YOU HAVEN'T SAID HER NAME
ONCE.
>> YEAH.
>> YOU HAVEN'T.
NO I HAVE NOT.
>> HE ALSO FINDS IT DIFFICULT TO
SPEAK ABOUT THE OTHER WOMAN IN
HIS LIFE T WOMAN HE WROTE THIS
FINAL GOODBYE TO.
MO'S MOTHER WAS SUFFERING FROM
CANCER AT HIS ARREST.
SHE DIED EARLIER THIS YEAR.
>> AND THAT IS PROBABLY -- OR IS
ONE OF THE THE BIGGEST REGRETS
THAT I HAVE IN MY LIFE.
STILL HAUNTS ME TO THIS DAY.
THAT I WOULD PREFER THIS WOMAN
THAT I'VE BEEN TOGETHER WITH FOR
UNDER A YEAR AND LIE TO MY
MOTHER ABOUT WHERE I WAS GOING.
>> HIS OTHER REGRET, THAT IN
TIME OF CONFUSION, ESPECIALLY
ABOUT HIS RELIGION, HE FAILED TO
REACH OUT TO HIS DAD, AN IMAM
HIMSELF, WHO WOULD NEVER HAVE
TAUGHT HIS SON TO KILL OR HURT
ANYONE.
>> I WISH I HAD JUST REACHED OUT
TO MY DAD.
IF I HAD JUST ASKED HIM, HE
WOULD JUST ILLUMINATE ME ON WHAT
WAS HAPPENING, WHAT'S REALLY
HAPPENING WITH THIS GROUP.
I FEEL LIKE THAT I SHOULD OWE
PEOPLE BACK TO SAY, HEY, DON'T
DO WHAT I DID.
IT'S -- THERE IS NO